Ian Lick: If you are building an application, press the camera button
The application crashes.
Joanna Smith: Any application?
Ian Lick: It does not matter which application.
It's a completely hypothetical position.
Joanna Smith: But by default, my apps do not collapse.
Ian Lake: Built Application.
Press the camera button and .. collapse.
He tries to have a better application, but he
He can not without your help.
Why do not you help, Joanna?
Joanna Smith: Wait,
What do you mean that I do not help?
I'm a very helpful person.
Ian Lake: If I were very helpful,
We've already talked about adding runtime checks
"Forbidden purposes".
(Music)
JOHANNA SMITH: Interesting, interesting fact, implicit purposes.
Ian: Like opening the camera application.
Joanna: Right.
It may not work on every device.
Ian: Well, it's not that they're not working on every device.
But in some devices the applications you need may not exist.
To respond to your need.
Joanna: Right.
This activates the "Exception of Lack of Activity"
And of course this is not happy news for your application.
Ian: This looks very serious, I mean
Serious to kill application.
Joanna: That's right. May lead to the collapse of your application.
This generally happens when
The application is missing, because the user
Scan or disable application.
Ian: What?
Survey?
Damage?
I mean, my favorite apps?
Joanna: Or it could be the user
What we call a "limited account" and do not enjoy using
All the features.
Ian: "Limited Accounts"?
Is this dangerous?
I mean, do we need someone to check it out?
Joanna: Or it could be a basic user
Minimize the applications and features available
For other users.
Ian: If the user is the primary device
Can i take my camera application?
Joanna: Well, I mean, yes,
But remember that the machines are assigned to the working environment
Or devices under parental control
You may not need a camera function.
Ian: But we can take Sylvie, right?
Ian: Oh, it's collapsed.
Joanna: Yes. To prevent run-time exceptions and landslides at an inappropriate time
It is very easy if you are only
You call "ResloveActivity" before launching your implicit purpose.
Ian: ResolveActivity, the problem has been resolved.
We are done.
Joanna: Yeah, it's really that simple.
Because just check to make sure
From having something to use before using it
Will make the entire application more stable.
Ian: Wow.
that's cool.
Does this mean we can take Sylvie?
Ian: Sylvie.
Ian: It's good.
Joanna: Yes. So use run-time tests to
Ian: Adopt better applications. Joanna: My son has better applications.
Thanks Ian.
(Music)